-I have made this
sort of my first question
to every senator
who's running for Presiden
because you are now --
you're still a senator.
And you're working with
a lot of colleagues
who also want to be President.
-Yes.
-Is it awkward?
-But you don't want to
be President?
-No. So it must be nice for yo
to finally sit
and talk to somebody.
-Yes. But, you know,
we are all friends,
as opposed to who is
in the White House right now
-Yes.
-And so actually when you look
at it, I have got -- let's see
Elizabeth and Bernie and I
are in leadership.
Michael Bennet --
I have been to his house a lot
Friends.
I'm emceeing this softball gam
that Kirsten is pitching
next week.
And then Kamala and Cory and I
served together on Judiciary
and after that,
Kavanaugh hearing.
That is a bond
that we will never break.
-Yeah, there you go.
You've been through something.
And then it will be
interesting, certainly.
The debates are coming up
in about two weeks.
It must be an interesting moment
to actually get out there
and be able to talk about
your position
with some of
your other competition.
-It is, because this is
a moment, especially for someone
like me from a state
that's a little smaller
in the middle of the country
for me to tell people
what I'm all about,
that I think that we need to
bring the heart back
to American politics.
We need to bring
people together
and not wake up every day
to a mean tweet, right?
-Yeah.
-That we need to
start talking about
things that matter to people -
bringing down the cost of
prescription drugs,
doing something about
the cost of college,
finally moving ahead on climat
change and immigration reform.
And it gives me that momen
to talk about what I stand for
and how we can have
a better America right now
-That would be
exciting to watch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You don't have to say.
There is
a Wednesday and Thursday,
and it's sort of a random draw
Do you have a preference?
Would you rather be --
-I don't know.
I think I -- We'll just se
what happens.
-Yeah, we'll see what happens.
You don't want to say Wednesda
and then all of a sudden,
you're a Thursday.
-Right.
And then it's already a loss
-Yeah, exactly.
-I just know I'm ahead of
18 people right now.
That's pretty good.
-You're ahead of 18 people
-Yeah, that's right.
-That's really exciting.
-Yeah, glass half full.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do want to talk about sort o
some of the broader issues
that affect everyday Americans
but there's this other,
and many people say maybe this
is a distraction from that
But you haven't spoken out
as far as where --
how you feel about impeachment
I don't want to put words
in your mouth.
But you were
a former prosecutor.
So having looked at
this evidence,
what is your take on it so far
-Well, I think that
there could be impeachment
And I personally --
if the impeachment --
when I look at this evidence
I see impeachment.
However, I think the House
right now has to be able
to finish their investigation,
right?
They're starting to
call witnesses.
They have one coming
before them.
That's really important.
But the other piece of this that
we have to be doing
at the same time is to look at
that Mueller report
and all of the allegations
about what Russia did.
And right now, as you pointe
out earlier in the show,
you got a guy in the White House
who is basically saying,
"Come on, foreign agents, give
me some dirt on my opponent.
That is what he said
in that interview.
And that is what we most fear.
And I know this personally
I've been trying to pass
this bill to at least
get some backup paper ballot
and audits.
And it's a bipartisan bill
And the White House stopped it
its tracks.
And now I know why.
I mean, he doesn't care
what happens in this electio
except he wants to win,
and he'll do anything to do it
And I think Americans
have got to understand
exactly what went on
so that we can stop it
from happening again.
-The other thing is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's a lot of distractions.
And I know you have made -
infrastructure was one of
the first things
you announced on your platform
The President --
I feel terrible for him --
10 times he's had
an infrastructure week.
And it's gotten derailed
and something's happened.
And they've ended up being
very empty infrastructure weeks.
-As in no infrastructure.
-There's literally
no infrastructure.
-Yeah.
Can you explain to people,
like, the importance of this
and sort of also
how the current administration
is just using it as a word
that means nothing?
-Exactly.
I think he says it
because it sounds good.
He said it on election night
I remember that.
And now nothing has happened
The latest is
he had the leaders over.
And then he blew up
when they said,
"Well, how are you
gonna pay for it?"
And that was the end of it
We never heard about it again.
-That is a famous sore spot him.
"How are you gonna
pay for something?"
-Exactly.
-So they should have known
better, yeah.
-Because he just
keeps adding debt.
-And he has also
personal money trouble.
-Okay, then. There you go.
Okay, so why is it important
Well, first of all, you hear
about this rural/urban divide.
Well, how are we gonna bridge it
if you can't e-mail your mom
in a small rural town
because the broadband doesn'
work, right?
So the idea is that we put -
I proposed a trillion dollars.
And I have exactly
how I'm gonna pay for it,
like bringing back some of
those corporate tax cuts.
Every point it goes down
is $100 billion.
And it can go for things
like our crumbling schools
They didn't have heat in some of
the schools in Baltimore.
Transit, green infrastructure,
making sure our bridges
and our roads are working.
Putting this money
into infrastructure
to bring America together.
This has always been
a bipartisan issue.
So I think
it's a good way to start.
And I have had the experience.
I think I've had now 100 bills
that have passed where I a
the lead Democrat.
I think experience does matter
-Yeah.
-You can actually
get something done
because we got a guy
in the White House right now
who had no experience
coming in there.
And we can get
things like this done.
And it is, to me, one of
the biggest hypocrisies
that he started his term
by saying this was something
he wanted to do.
And he has not done anything
-Well, I'm certainly looking
forward to hearing more from you
in a couple of weeks, be i
on a Wednesday or Thursday
And thanks so much
for being here.
-Okay, thank you.
Thank you for having me.
-Senator Amy Klobuchar.